you know after what we've seen in the
last year that new rail is really really
significantly needed as much as rumble
is needed as a video platform i actually
believe that the actual rail the cloud
the the infrastructure the service is
really really needed
for the entire internet the free and
open internet is under attack and we
need to provide the rail as a common
carrier as close to a common carrier as
possible for for everyone else out there
all the other businesses
all the other you know churches
everything universities it's it kind of
spreads into every sector out there and
we really want to provide that
infrastructure
dave reuben and joining me today is the
ceo of rumble
chris pavlovsky welcome to the reuben
report
dave thanks for having me really excited
to to be on today
all right i guess we have to do like the
disclaimers or whatever you want to call
it right up front yes everybody knows
that
rumble and locals have merged there was
an acquisition so this is not going to
be an attackia kind of interview but the
reason we wanted to do this was to to
clarify some of the reasons that we're
doing this partnership in the first
place so i'm just putting that part out
there before i do anything else can you
just tell me a little bit about how and
why you created rumble because this is
not something that just magically
appeared out of nowhere a year ago
you've been working on this thing for a
long time
no i have for sure so i've i've actually
been in the space for
two decades now i started uh
it was like 2001 so yeah exactly two
decades and i remember it was about
2005. i had one of my friends send me an
icq message or an msn messenger message
and they're like hey check this site out
and it was youtube and at the time my
friend owned like the top 50 website on
the internet
uh in video
and he's like these guys are gonna crush
me they're they're well funded i got
nothing i won't be able to keep up with
the funding and they're gonna win and
you know fast forward two years
youtube sucks up all the oxygen in the
room google buys them google puts them
into the search engine
and uh they end up being the de facto
video platform
on the internet post 2007 2008
and kind of monopolize the entire not
kind of they monopolize the entire video
sphere
online
so it puts all of us out of business
that own any video sites or small sites
were you know no longer existing and
then it wasn't until about
2010 where i started seeing
a a shift change
a real change in the way youtube was
doing things they introduced
multi-channel networks they introduced
uh
you know a lot of preferencing on big
corporations and icons so it was about
it it took me till about 2013 where i
said you know it's time to get back into
this space it really seems to me that uh
that the incumbent platform youtube at
the time um is starting to really
deprioritize the small creator and
really prioritize those multi-channel
networks big influencers
large brands large corporations and the
our aunts and our uncles and our friends
and family no longer really had any kind
of space or real estate
on on these platforms anymore so we
started rumble in 2013 to really bring
back that fairness and really help that
small creator get access to those tools
get access to the monetization get
access to everything that those mcns
were giving creators access to
and we built a pretty good business in
2013 and it it was a good business all
the way up until uh 2020 and then it
became a really good business in 2000
and
i would say starting in 2018 and ford it
became a really really good business
um by 2020
everything hits the fan
it was
it was like 11 o'clock at night in the
middle of the summer and i remember a
congressman signing up to our to our
site and i was like holy [ __ ] like why
is a congressman
signing up to rumble like um this being
a canadian a canadian video platform
that was that was a pretty big deal
um and i remember going to my colleague
and saying hey
is this real is this a real sign up and
we looked at it and we we think it was
real it seemed like it was real uh and a
week later i'm on the phone with this
congressman and he asks me a simple
simple question
if i put my content on rumble
will i be able to find it in search if i
search my name
and when we're like yeah that seems
pretty standard
uh it should come up in our search if
someone searches for you and he's like
well that's not happening anywhere else
on the internet it's not happening on
youtube so i am going to bring it over
to to rumble within three months
less than that two months he accumulates
over 300 000 subscribers on rumble and
in the very same period over five
actually a longer period five years on
being on youtube he only had 10 000
subscribers
so you can kind of see how
that happened and when that did happen
and everybody noticed
everything hit the fan everyone started
hearing about rumble people were like
growing faster on rumble the message
went out this congressman was on tv
telling everybody go to rumble um we
should tell you i know who the answer is
but we should tell people who the
congressman was
it was congressman devin nunes um he was
uh he was the very first person um
in the political spirit to come on to
rumble and uh realize this problem that
was happening and uh when it did happen
he was out on tv letting everybody know
that hey like i'm growing faster on
rumble and i'm getting more views on
rumble than i am getting on youtube and
it wasn't long after that till everybody
started following and
jumping on a rumble and it took us to
we're in 2021 now and in august we saw
the largest month we've ever seen on our
platform a tremendous amount of growth
from where we were six months ago seven
eight months ago
the largest single growth in a single
month was in august
and we haven't looked back since and
it's been super exciting we we you know
we did the the merger and i want to call
it a merger well it's not really an
acquisition and i think we should really
you know explore that a little bit more
but the merger with you and becoming
partners with you and us off is uh is
the the next major moment in this
business and i and i'm super excited to
to uh to be here with you
and talk through this so before we get
into that stuff can you just tell people
a little bit about
what you actually have built like when
people think oh you're trying to compete
with youtube or you're trying to compete
with amazon aws like these sound like
impossible feats and you know as well as
i like i went into enough board rooms to
tell people what we were doing with
locals and they're just like no the big
boys exist like accept it and move on
yeah and this is really like looking
under the hood and it's really important
it's a great question so one of the
things we did is we did when we built
rumble we built it the old-fashioned way
like i said i've been in this for two
decades i've been working off bare metal
in my own servers since the day i
started in
2001 or two or whatever it was
um and i never really did it any other
way all these fancy words cloud and aws
and amazon i never subscribed to that
and when we started rumble we we put in
our own servers we put in use our own
bare metal and we built our own
infrastructure from the ground up and we
didn't look back and how we did that
and you know it wasn't something that i
thought was necessarily
uh it wasn't like hey we need to do this
because we need to compete against them
it was like hey we need to do this
because it's going to save us costs it's
better it's just you know we own
everything it's uh we don't want to give
anybody access to that data we want to
make sure that's all under our hood and
not under someone else's hood and that's
kind of why we did it and you know you
come to 2020 in 2019 2020 and 2021
it ends up being a real real good
decision but that's not to say that we
didn't look into the future a little bit
with it when we started rumble we saw
rumble as like two things
and one was to compete aggressively
against youtube and the video platform
as much as possible
and but if we successfully do that it
means that we'll now have the scale to
go really compete against all these
incumbent cloud services remember
um you when you look at uh
at google in google cloud what do they
have that makes their infrastructure so
large youtube when you look at amazon
aws what do they have that makes their
infrastructure really large it's
amazon.com and twitch when you look at
microsoft azure you you look at xbox you
look at these things that really allow
them to have real competitive advantage
on the infrastructure side when you look
at rumble and now that rumble's become a
formidable size we now have um that that
advantage to really offer a cloud
services really offer a new rail and
you know after what we've seen in the
last year that new rail is really really
significantly needed as much as rumble
is needed as a video platform i actually
believe that the actual rail the cloud
the the infrastructure the service is
really really needed
for
the entire internet the free and open
internet is under attack and we need to
provide the rail as a common carrier as
close to a common carrier as possible
for for everyone else out there all the
other businesses all the other you know
churches everything universities it's it
kind of spreads into every sector out
there and we really want to provide that
infrastructure so i'm sure many people
are watching this going so let me get
this straight if parlor let's say had
been on rumble infrastructure using
rumble infrastructure after january 6
would parlor still be here right now
absolutely
rumble's still around um
right
i think that's a testament to
to where we are and what we're doing
uh rumble rumbles around and uh rumble
will be around and we're going to
continue to build that rail and build
that new economy for for everyone not
just for rumble.com and locals but for
everyone and let me get this straight
chris our policy is that people can
basically say what they want and we're
not going to decide who the winners or
losers are and if maybe somebody broke
the laws of the united states they have
a bigger problem than chris and dave is
that could we be doing something so
radical like that
yeah
you know i think that the best way to
look at it is that we got to get to
becoming a com as close to a common
carrier as possible we're not a
publisher we don't want to get in
editorial control we want to tell people
what they can or can't say if you're
having an argument at the dinner table
why can't you have that argument when
you're online if you're having a
discussion or having an opinion
why can't that be online this is the
free and open internet as free as your
dinner table there's no difference in my
mind and there shouldn't be and what
we've seen happen in the last 10 years
on the internet is this
huge tilting to kind of shut everybody
up regardless of of your political views
they just every they want to shut down
the conversation that we all have at our
dinner tables and that's just
it boggles my mind because when you look
back 10 15 years ago and you look at
these incumbent platforms they were all
preaching the free and open internet i
even think i saw twitter
uh twitter verified or twitter i'm not
sure twitter policy say that they want a
free and open internet in in nigeria and
like
where is that and the rest of the world
like right
they're still pretending they want a
free and open internet but it really is
not and i think that you know us
building the rails to that
and really providing an open
communication platform like rumble are
are small pieces but but important
pieces to to making sure the internet
stays free and stays open so i want to
flash back to all the way
in june of this past year june 2021
assaf my partner and locals and i we met
you in miami we had a couple plans we
thought all right we're going to present
this guy with some partnership ideas you
know we can work together in some ways
and i've said this a couple times
publicly but literally before the water
was even poured at the table we had sat
down for about 20 seconds you said guys
i want to merge with you how do we make
this thing happen
so why were you interested in locals you
know created by this wacky youtuber
[Laughter]
well hey that that's a pretty easy one
uh you you you've built something that
is really important and uh
what you've built is you've allowed
creators to basically build
subscriptions
in their own way allowing creators to to
have autonomy and independence uh on a
different stream of revenue right
rumble's been primarily
since we started it's been based off of
advertising and advertising is to be
frank it can be a weakness in this
environment and we don't want to fall
pressure to that type of weakness so by
having like
having locals and having a revenue
stream that's protected by subscriptions
and allowing creators to have that
independence
is something that i've admired and i've
always wanted to get towards we've built
rumble rants we've built in tipping but
then i said to myself like why would we
compete against someone that has the
same philosophy as us that thinks the
same way as us and we're up against the
largest thing the largest companies on
the planet we're up against a monopoly
um
it makes no sense to be doing it to be
doing it with less resources and being
really small you can't fight like
trillion dollar entities with a couple
million dollars like you're not gonna
win it's just it's impossible you need
to really kind of bring in all the minds
bring in all the resources and really
and really do it together and i felt
like one of the things that seems to
happen a lot is that everyone wants to
kind of build their own thing and kind
of go at it their own way without really
kind of doing it together collectively
in a unified way and i felt like you
know
we've we've been talking to us off for
quite some time i i felt like there was
a real opportunity after meeting you
guys
in person and then doing it
many other times following that meeting
it just made more sense to unify and and
to do this as a collective resource and
to put all our brains together
and to do it together and that's what
this is this isn't uh this isn't just me
this isn't just you anymore it's not
just it's all of us and it's all of us
going to go up against
the monopoly and that and and that's
going to take it's going to take more
than just us at the end of the day we're
going to need more than than just us but
like at this point i think this was the
the perfect marriage it allows rumble to
be a lot more defensible we now have a
subscription revenue stream um and it
allows us to be a lot more bold on the
advertising front the things that we
have planned you know we've we've
discussed on the advertising stuff is
really bold and i can't wait till we we
go to market with those strategies but
now that we have locals and we're
together we can now do that and we can
do things and we can innovate in the
market the way we couldn't innovate
before so that you know i think for me
it was it was a no-brainer uh to combine
and work with the two yourself and assaf
i think you know
this is this is the perfect synergy and
for us you know it gave us not only the
infrastructure we needed but resources
but i think you really hit it which is
that we all vibe like we all know what
the threat is we all want to fight it
and you know you said collective a
couple times and it's like my audience
freaks out at the word collective but
like sometimes you've got to team with
people to beat these things so let's
just get into some of the some of the
specifics of the deal and how we're
going to work together because a lot of
people in my local community and on
youtube and on rumble we're asking about
some of the specifics so first off
locals is going to continue to operate
as is we just have better resources
behind us but a soft will continue to
run it you're not looking to take over
locals anything else you want to say on
that
yeah like the our our vision and it was
from day one is that we'll use rumble to
funnel a massive audience to locals for
your creators bring them more
subscribers integrate it into rumble
allow or allow the rumble audience to
really find locals creators and
subscribe to their pages a real true
discovery for locals what drives the
bottom line for all the creators in
addition to that the other thing that we
thought was really compelling was in
necessary and absolutely necessary is to
get locals on the rumble rail is to is
to utilize that infrastructure so that
you're protected and that you can
continue to fulfill your promise of
allowing freedom of expression and
allowing people to
to to
have their own opinions and have their
discussions the way they want to have
without anybody impeding that and you
know
my philosophy is that the way locals is
being run right now and
has been phenomenal there's there's no
reason for anybody to step in front of
that and that's not what this is what
this is is that locals is going to be
running independently rumble's going to
be running independently and we're going
to utilize those resources bring in that
distribution from rumble really help
that locals community and really you
know protect that locals community on an
infrastructure point of view nothing
else changes why would anything else
changes that's that's not going to help
anybody can you talk about the data and
content side of this also because when i
started this thing it was purely because
i needed a place that i would own my
content my video my audio etc and i
needed a place where if i got booted off
everything else i could actually still
communicate with my audience that's
exactly how we built locals but i saw
some people they're saying uh oh now now
rumble's gonna have all of that data you
won't have it as the creator but uh i
don't want to give you too much of a
leading question here that's actually
not the case
you know it's funny because i i was
actually talking about this like a year
ago and i've been having this
conversation for months uh since that
that first time that i that i explored
this i've always wanted
every creator on rumble to own their
data i think that's imperative i think i
wrote an article a long time ago about
that and that was one of the key ways to
kind of really kind of get back into
this market is really making sure that
the creators are independent and own
that data for us to like have that data
on rumble that's not
that's not the mission here the mission
is to make sure that creators stay
independent the mission is to protect
the crater economy more than ever and
protect their opinions and protect what
they want to do it would be it would
make no sense to be doing the complete
opposite of why why these businesses are
are succeeding today like we are here to
like
change the crater economy give them more
autonomy give them more independence i i
really think this is the wheel the next
wave of web 3.0 call it whatever you
want but it's truly the next wave and i
think locals is on the forefront of that
and rumble needs to catch up and and do
more of that and that's what locals
allows us to do is like now we can
accelerate on that imagine having all
your subscribers on rumble being
portable that should be possible that's
what we should stand for that's what the
creator economy deserves those are
that's their audience for us to be able
to take that away from them is not right
and that's it and that's what locals is
doing they've changed that if anything
locals is gonna get rumbled to do the
same thing the locals is doing not the
vice versa and to be clear that's
complete 180 the reverse of what happens
on twitter youtube elsewhere like i have
no way of contacting my 1.7 or whatever
it is million youtube subscribers
because they own the access to those
people i don't have direct communication
with them one of the things that i saw
pop up a couple times when we announced
this was people were concerned that
rumble is a canadian company you are a
scary canadian with that draconian
government you have over there do we
have any plans on that front
so we did announce that we were opening
up a us headquarters uh in longboat key
in sarasota county down in florida so uh
we'll be neighbors uh to locals i think
locals isn't wine i know locals is in
miami and uh we'll be on the other side
of the coast but uh
yeah we're we're definitely having we're
we're planting a large presence in the
united states and we're super excited
about that that's uh
the business climate in florida is is is
amazing um the county's been amazing and
uh one of the things i like about it is
that you know rumble gets a lot of
support from small towns in the united
states not in big cities but small towns
a lot of it and going into a small town
is is super exciting to me i think you
know supporting a community like that
and really
in really bringing rumble to a community
like that rather than picking a large
city is uh is uh super exciting i i'm
looking forward to it but yeah i
understand everybody's concerns about
being uh in canada that those are those
are those are concerns um
i don't you know we don't know where
that's gonna go here in canada yet the
laws are still kind of you know
not they haven't been passed yet but
it's definitely a concern i think a lot
of companies are expressing that concern
and at this point right now like we'll
have our u.s headquarters in in sarasota
and i don't think there's anything for
anybody to worry about at this point is
there anything else on the tech side
that we should let people know that
maybe i haven't let them know or bongino
hasn't let them know or that you just
want people to know about what it is
that we're building
so there's you know
the rumble cloud is something that we're
going to put a lot of focus on obviously
our first priority right now is to make
sure that we get locals onto this cloud
we we've brought on a lot of customers
on the cloud side um and it's funny
because we're not even really
proactively selling it we've made some
statements that we have it and we've had
a lot of incoming and we've onboarded a
lot of different clients um some very
large ones as well so there's going to
be a lot of a lot of stuff on the cloud
front um we're going to be launching
that rumble cloud in the in the near
future
but but in terms of locals in rumble
there's going to be a lot of
you know tech integration there as well
not just on the cloud side but on the
front side um being able to access the
locals content through rumble being able
to discover it having your accounts to
be able to connect not on a data
perspective so we're not taking the data
but on a perspective of like being able
to say hey you have a locals account and
advertise that locals account on your
rumble page so you can go there and
convert and maybe even convert them
straight from the rumble page into the
locals community so there's a lot of
work on that front um we also have our
new app coming out that'll be out in q1
of uh 2022 hopefully sooner but let's
say q1 2022 which is going to have a
completely new interface i know that's
been a huge complaint and i i agree you
know when you're a bootstrap company and
you never raised money uh
since like five six months ago you know
you kind of you don't really have the
the cash resources to go out there and
build that fancy user interface you kind
of focus on the core infrastructure
which we have done uh and but now that
we were a little more capitalized we can
uh we can build that interface that
everyone's looking for and we have been
and we're working on that you know every
single day
so we do all that
we fix the internet and
then uh what we just
hang out on a boat what do we do after
that
oh i don't know about that but uh in
terms of we got a lot of work to do in
terms of fixing the internet right now
we have a we right now that that free
and open internet is is under attack and
i think it's going to take many years
before we
we we we fix that but
definitely that's that's the only thing
that i have on my on my agenda right now
is making sure that we fight back on
that well chris i just want to say you
know it is also i've mentioned it on the
show you know we did an all stock deal
here which we didn't have to do we had
cash offers and assaf and i believed not
only in the in the idea that you've
presented here but uh but you and the
team has just been like like this was
this was all kind of a no-brainer even
though it can get tricky with lawyers
and everything else uh it all kind of
fit and i think people are now seeing a
hope for that parallel internet or or
social media 3.0 or or whatever you want
to call it so i know you have work to do
that perhaps is more important than than
talking to me any any final thoughts
no no the work is to make sure that the
community understands what this is and
understands that we're here for them and
we're gonna we're gonna fight for them
and uh we're listening to them and i
think that's
really important that they know that
we're listening uh you know i go through
every i try to go through as much as i
possibly can in terms of comments and
what they say
um you know one of the things i noticed
is that they say that you sold
you sold but really it wasn't a sale
it's really just combining forces right
now this is a merge this is this is a
merger and
i think you know we're stronger because
of it
and we're listening to all the feedback
that's coming in and that's what i love
about you guys and
and i think that's really important is
to always really have our ear to the
ground and understanding what our
community is saying because we have to
deliver them what they want and if we
don't we don't deserve to be in business
all right here's what we're going to do
i'm going to put you on the spot this
was not pre-planned but when we post
this video
uh i am going to ask you
to respond to questions in my locals
community people can ask whatever they
want and let's get you in there actually
responding to people this is sort of the
complete reverse of what zuckerberg
would do or jack from twitter or the
rest of these guys but let's get you in
the community and if people have
questions they can go to
reubenreport.locals.com and ask you
questions directly right from the the
video itself how about that
absolutely i look forward to that i i
will do that and i will do i will try to
do that forever all right chris i got
nothing better to do than save the world
i look forward to continuing the
adventure with you
sounds good thanks a lot for having me
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our tech playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell